here's Lowry charging right away
deflected by out of Miles stolen by
Murray one man to beat Murray goes up
throws it down and the foul
again it starts with the defense active
hand Murray comes up with the steal all
by himself Breakaway tells Max truth
mind your business
line flips to Watford spins away
oh
[Applause]
my gosh
oh man oh oh man he went back and got
something else didn't he yeah yeah he
did I'm gonna go back and just take a
little more yeah no his back was itching
he scratches back with him pulled him
pulled it back
put it back
now you coach Drew Eubanks as part of a
Pac-12 team in Australia Mike remember
is that correct yeah
Morant
posterizing through Eubanks
that man is a family
Leonard draws a double in the corner
movement
hello hello
destroys Randall inside
Norman Powell turns that corner goes all
the way over to the other side now he
simply elevates up over the top
here's Carter stolen by Dodgers could be
fun
as well
Luca orchestrating and manipulating the
half court but in transition he's got
some bunnies
ducking on true holiday of all people
[Music]
Jaren on the pick-off conchar hangs
floats punch
I guess look at this look at that there
on the back of Anthony Davis concert
goes up here every day he's just into
tight he didn't know he didn't see him
Jared Jackson Jr though
it's down by as many as 16 in this game
don't Destroyer
as Caruso on him backing in
continues to go to work with a move and
the throw down right here look at Scotty
B going to work in the paint
oh Big Time move right there one minute
gone by in the fourth
Nets turn it over Levert ahead Mitchell
poster
Donovan Mitchell
[Applause]
but that's also YouTube's got to do you
gotta understand so he decided to get
into the paint and then jump and contest
for Indiana so 85-67 to count Miranda
against McConnell Pickett roll Miranda
oh bye whoa
whoa look at this
Zack Hammer look how far back he
it look at growing back to the free
throw line and then come back and put it
down
Jalen Smith
had a clean look here comes Aaron Gordon
the other way
drink this in with your eyes ladies and
gentlemen
and that is Landry shamet there to take
the charge
it didn't hurt the Bulls they only got
one free throw one point made there's a
double team
s
[Applause]
oh my goodness wow
finds Hardaway Maneuvers away from the
closeout Luca Maneuvers away from a
closeout
[Applause]
we've ever seen that's real nice
it's been a timeout call but we ain't
going nowhere we're gonna let you look
at this again a time or two
look at that face
Walker finally sees NOS now to sharpen
the corner let's go let's go
[Applause]
Blazers Trail by 23 going forward on the
floor it's a successful three
[Music]
it's next 10 on the floor
[Applause]
no other human in the world
we will not forget that one I wanted to
beat this Bulls team a week ago today in
Spectrum Center
Hornets had a great finishing kick in
that win oh my God what was that Dennis
Smith raised the roof with Guy Roofing
and posterize it
I'm fairly certain that there is blood
right now
[Applause]
and to foul on Trey Young
and the Aaron Fox just take a look at
the elevation
and
let your opponent know that you're
coming with the force driving Closeouts
getting to the pain and knocking down a
deep three-pointer on that last
possession
sixes are out of fouls Johnson teeing
off puts it Down Beth was vicious
[Applause]
in the pulse game just about the lack of
energy the transition oh no don't do
that on him
thank you
talk about an exclamation point
Steel's been a forgotten guys since
early in the game
there's the seal Boston needs
[Music]
[Applause]
man to the parking lot where'd he go
got his old rebound stripped
Gordon no call
Derek white 11 points in a starting roll
tonight
indeed shake and bake
[Applause]
wolves not as sharp as they need to be
defensively
Edwards oh man
on his head
Edwards driving kids
[Applause]
this is amazing Anthony Edwards loaded
up and unpacking the TNT on alperin
shangoon says take all of this leather
in your face
[Music]
[Applause]
no rebound Wagner
way ahead to Van Carroll then Cara way
up and throws it down
karate
[Applause]
Rowdy David Ronnie with a Throwdown
with one side of the court to the other
and the Bulls take advantage of it on
that three Beasley's Off the Bench ready
to check in on the next whistle here's
marketing drives paint
[Applause]
they're rushing some of the shots mark
rushing a little lack of confidence at
times
largest lead of the night timeout
Toronto
[Music]
buddy again guarded by Garland
he couldn't get into the shooting mode
that one but take that I mean Lee Smith
was fired up
it's over
Pals no no no get it done and on the
[Applause]
about the entire year and he was pretty
emotional after the game last night
speechless
for Milwaukee
artist with the Lefty flush plus the
foul when he's got that type of momentum
that type of strength straight line
drive